dolly parton bows out of the rock and
roll hall of fame
good for her i don't blame her like [ __ ]
you i'm dolly parker who needs your
award yeah i'm dolly parton [ __ ] you she
even said i'm not even rock and roll the
coolest thing you could do is say no to
the rock and roll hall of fame i think
first of all she wasn't like asked to be
in the rock and roll hall of fame they
put her on the ballot right now being
nominated yeah and she's like wait a
second you mean people like john hein
and gary delabonke are gonna vote on
whether i'm worthy of this
really and larry de la bonkey
said he wasn't gonna vote for her i
don't know boss i think it's premature i
didn't say that i don't know what you
said the point is imagine how insulting
it is for a woman who wrote some of the
greatest songs in history to have gary
delabonke
voting on whether she's worthy of being
in the rock and roll hall of fame
you follow i do you see how dumb that is
i i for you yes we don't even know how
you vote how do you vote
well first of all like a monkey i put
the pencil in my hand no no no i'm like
what have you got to do with rock and
roll i worked at a record store when i
was in high school
first i asked myself well what really
has she done in her career she's no
flock of seagulls ball
faba bowie baba bowie and let's face it
not every song she wrote is a hit she
had a few stumbles in her catalog baba
bowie no offense to gary or john if
there was an organization
that i had to
lobby those two
to get into
well at least like if you get nominated
for an oscar
actors and actresses and directors are
voting dolly you see that guy over there
with a huge teeth
yes
you have to go suck up to him
we think he might be voting for steely
dan instead of you
oh by all means by the way
lobbying to us well gary what's your
credentials for voting on dolly parton i
own over 2000 pieces of vinyl
i was the one who brought 99 luff
balloons to record weather
i own a jukebox
the idea that dolly parton is being
voted on by judge
judged by zero time platinum artist gary
de la bonkey
i'm just that guy when it comes to
musical knowledge that's why the rock
and roll hall of fame turns to me
[Music]
[Laughter]
can you imagine this woman this woman
sat in a room
riding jolene and i will always love you
nine to five
shabby cabin i don't you know she didn't
come for money there was no music
lessons you don't even play an
instrument gary oh i play trumpet with
james brown
[Music]
gary's the guy who judged the ipad and
gave it a thumbs down
is the ipad another breakthrough for
apple in a lot of ways it was a bit of a
stumble for them there's a lot of things
that are missing from the ipad for me
i'm trying to figure out who's it for
who should i vote for to defend himself
is uh gary delabate audiobook these
aren't necessarily my favorite songs
these are songs that just sound
unbelievable on a jukebox
so
i'll start with uh suspicious minds by
elvis presley just sounds great on the
jukebox
see dolly that's who's voting for you
god bless dolly parton i'm very proud of
her